Caleb Williams has Heisman number two on
his mind but these guys are hoping to
keep the USC star from becoming the
second two-time Heisman winner in
college football history Caleb is the
Heisman favorite but he needs to get
past a tough Pac-12 loaded with top QB
such as Oregon's bow Knicks Washington's
Michael penix Jr and Utah's cam Rising
let's not sleep on Marvin Harrison Jr
who's looking to follow Devante Smith's
footsteps and become a rare wide
receiver Heisman winner the son of the
Colts Hall of Famer is making a name for
himself with insane catches like these
at Ohio State Drake May is a baller who
had over 4 300 yards and 38 touchdowns
as a first-year starter for UNC last
season Jaden Daniels will be another
name to keep an eye on after leading LSU
to a win over Alabama and a trip to the
SEC Championship game last season
Florida State's hype is built around
Jordan Travis and don't sleep on Texas's
Quinn yours he has us wondering if Texas
might actually be back throw in
Michigan's JJ McCarthy and Blake Coram
and Williams has a ton of competition
that's looking to prevent the Heisman
repeat